hey everybody Craig willett here I just
want to tell you about the little
promotion that actually big promotion
that the film courage is doing for the
straight on till morning a kickstarter
campaign first glance films as offering
this awesome real production calendar or
software for the first person who
donates two hundred fifty dollars or
more to the campaign by 5 p.m. pacific
standard time tomorrow monday what's the
date shoot it's a Monday May tenth
Monday May tenth at five p.m. pacific
standard time first person to donate two
hundred fifty dollars or more by that
point we'll get this awesome software
from first glance films so